O
Benim bugünkü konuşma özellikle
geleceğin meslekleri üzerine olacak
şimdi düşünün kendinizi düşünün ve
çocuklarınızı düşünün gençler kendinizi
düşünün aramızda
12sınıf mezunları yok ama
2022 yılında messi'den mezun olacaklar
var Şunu da oturalım 2020/3 yılı lise
mezunları onuncu sınıfta olanlar
2024 mezun olacaklar 90 oturan iki
arkadaş ise 2025 mezun olacak Belki
hazırlık sınıfında olanlar 2026 mezun
olacaklar liseden ve yarın sınava
girecek olan çocuklar ise 2026 ve 2027
öğrenciler olacaklar Bakın bu çok önemli
bir konu neden derseniz mezun olduktan
sonra liseyi bitirdikten sonra tam dört
yıl koyuyoruz farzedelim 2022 yıl 2020
Üçler güzel bir yıl Türk Cumhuriyet
tarihinin 100'üncü yılı 2 çok küçük
üzerine dört yıl koyduğunuzda 2020'ye
diye geliyorsunuz
2027 üzerine toplam üniversiteden mezun
etimizin üzerine kız ile 60 yıl değer
üretiyorsunuz yani Aslında bugün burada
ben Sınıfınızdaki arkadaşlarınız Ya da
evdeki çocuklarımızın kardeşlerinizi
düşünün küçük küçük çocukları
düşündüğünüzü Ben aslında onların 2067
2087 dininden konuşuyorum Dün üç buçuk
yaşında bir çocuk geldi bana anne okul
ve yuva seçimi için bana sordu Ben
genelde lise ve üniversite öğrencileri
de çalışıyorum ama çok küçük kesimde de
bu kadar erken yaş bile meraklı anneler
için soru geliyor düşünebiliyor musunuz
bu çocuğun hayatını düşündüğünüzde 2100
yılının 2103 yılını bulabiliyoruz Yani
bugün Aslında sevgili öğretmenler
sevgili aileler ve sevgili gençler Gitti
Ha kendiniz Aslında 2020'den 2030 ları
değil 2050 lira mm 60-70 Bu
düşüneceğiniz bir dünyanın kapısını yeni
bir bayrak açıyorsunuz son durum ve Son
duruma size biraz bahsetmek istiyorum Bu
konuda uyanıklık sağlığımızı bekliyorum
Bir gerçekten pandemi bitiyor gel son
iki yıl çok zor geçti 21 20 Mart'tan
sonra Ama özellikle da hiç görmediğimiz
çok önemli bir ekonomik krize karşı
karşıya kalacağız Bu ekonomik kriz
Türkiye'yi ilgilendiren bir ekonomik
krizi değil bu bütün dünyayı etkileyen
mi İnik kapitalizmin tekrardan revize
edileceği artık taşıyamayacağı bir
kapitalist sistemin gitme dönemindeyiz
Ayrıca tabii ki çok yakın bir
zamanımızda yakınımızda çok yoğun olan
bir savaşla içeceğiz Bunu niye
anlatıyorum Eğer krizi bilirsen krizde
neler olacağını görürse Bu anlamda ne
gibi bir fark yaratıyor öncesinden
tedbirli davranın ve ona göre
değerlendirmek gerekiyor o yüzden sizin
bu içinde şunu bir yolunuz lazım ki mm
gerçekten 21 yüzyıl Bu anlamda
bakıldığında tam anlamıyla mm bir yılı
itibariyle başlamadı Aslında yeni video
dönemem Belkide endüstri40 diye
tanımladığımız önü Biz için bakıldığında
Tamda pandomin başladı dönem bir prize
başlayarak devam etti ve Bu kriz
bambaşka yeni bir dünyayı açı olacak bu
değiştirecek ofisleri değiştirdim
değiştirmeye devam edecek teknoloji
değiştirdi değiştirmeye devam edecek
bankacılık Tıp Ve tabiki eğitim çok
ciddi şekilde değişecek eğitim
değişmesiyle beraber iş dünyasında büyük
değişimler olacak inanılmaz bir işsizlik
var emanetini verdiği bilgiye göre
18 milyon insanın 3 milyar işsiz kalacak
Peki ne yapacağız Nasıl bir yol
izleyeceğiz nerede problem var
Türkiye'de işsizlik var nasıl çözeceğiz
diye bize çok soru soruluyor bunu ilk
sorulardan bir tanesi şu Aslında iş var
bu iş var Ama
öğrencilerin kimse ettiği tanımladığımız
becerileriyle iş dünyasının beceri
örtüşmüyor adeta şöyle iş dünyası bunu
istiyorum üniversiteler bunu veriyor
orada İkisi bir minimatch etmediği için
gerçek anlamda üniversiteden çıkın
öğrenci işsiz kalabiliyor ya da iyice
kadar birinci derecede istenilen noktaya
gelemiyor O zaman ne yapmak lazım işte
burada çok önemli devreye girecek konu
var O soru Üniversitesi'nin vermiş
olduğu bilgiye göre bu çok önemli iki üç
yılında bunu İngiliz halkına değil bütün
dünyaya söyledi Hey sevgili aileler
Maalesef ki çocuklarınızın sadece
okulları teslim edemezsiniz okullarla
birlikte beraber Sizinde devrede
bulunuyor olmanız ve konusundaki uzman
insanlarla çalışarak bu konuda daha
sofistike bir eğitim vermeye olmamız
gerekiyor dedi neden okuldan gitmiyor
siz de biliyorsunuz hocalarım müfredat
bir tarafta çocuğun sırt bu test ayrı
birer Siz neredeyse bugün Robert Koleji
gidin Galatasaray Lisesi'nin gidin
öğrenci buraya Burada da aynı şey mi
Muhtemelen öyledir öğrenci 11012 sınıfta
neredeyse okula gelmiyor nerede
dershanede geçiriyor acayip manyak gibi
ders alıyor aynı şeyi 18 için de geçerli
78 sınıfta bir Dershane hikayesi DGS
girmeye çalışıyor üniversite
geldiklerini Boğaziçi Üniversitesi
Cerrahpaşa ki biliyorsunuz
Türkiye'nin en iyi üniversiteleri Bunlar
en azından şimdilik diyebiliyoruz bu
anlamda baktığınızda oraya gelen değil
bir de ki çocuğun ilk 11'deki çocuğun
gerçek anlamda yaratıcılığını
bitirdiğini ve test formatında düşündüğü
için biz onu ilk seni Hatta cilalamak
zorunda kalıp tekrardan onun çiçek
açmasını sebebiyet vermeye çalışıyoruz
Çünkü neden o kadar testten çıkmış
oluyor ki o kadar Mantık düz bakıyor ki
noktadan sonra büyük harf o neydi unutan
Bunu ifade edemeyen beş cümle fikir
verdiğini nasıl hocam Ne fikri
verebileceğim değil değerlendiriyorsunuz
bir almışım
çocuk bu test mantığından çıkıldığını
özel Bu dönem içinde mutlaka önemli bir
yaratıcılık taraflarına geliştirilmesi
gerekiyor ve bu gençlerin özellikle
üniversite seçimlerinde yani meslek
seçimlerini çok dikkat ediliyor olması
gerekiyor Bugün dünyayı en önemli beş
tane alan büyük bir şekilde Transformers
edecek olamayacağımız derecede büyüklüğe
Transformers son sağlayacak bu trans
formasyondaki ilk en önemli ajanda
lardan bir tanesi sizce hangisi Tabii ki
yazılım bugün bana gelip ailelerde var
ki hocam Hiç merak etme en popüler
meslek yazılım ya Tamam biz karar verdik
yazılım okutacağız diyor Fakat burada
yine bir problemle karşı karşıyayız
çünkü Bu yazılım dediğin konu bildiğin
coater Aslında Normalde 21. yüzyılda
mavi yakalı işçisinin adı Yani kısacası
38 saat kırk saat durmamacasına çalışan
gençler istemiyoruz biz o yazılımcıların
yönlendiren bilişim teknolojileri
konusundaki uzmanları expertise
yetişmesini istiyoruz bu nedenden dolayı
en önemli ajandaları mızdan bir tanesi
bu yazılım meselesindeki 62 tane yepyeni
konu açıldı Bunlar yapar zekâdan makine
öğrenmesi ne data servisten aklınıza
gelmeyecek kadar ayoti niye kontörlü
internet şimdi Monster doktorun
programları açıldı buna inanılmaz yeni
alan siz gidiyorsunuz çocuğa diyorsunuz
yazılım oku yani o çocuğu için mi olsun
istiyorsunuz Hayır tabii ki değil bu
anlamda O yüzden bunları çok iyi
ayrıştırılması değerlendirmesi gerekiyor
Bunlar çok iyi bilinir şekillendiriyor
olması gerekiyor o yüzden ya bu
konusundaki o derin iyi ayarlamak
gerekiyor ikinci önemli konulardan bir
tanesi mesleğimiz geleceğin meslekleri
açısından en kıymetlisi yaşam bilimleri
bakıp değil
içinde tıbbında olduğu yaşam bilimleri
alanında büyük değişim olacak Aranızda
kaç kişi gençler de çocukları arasında
yaşam bilimleri alanında çalışmayı
düşününüz var var böyle bir var mı
aranızda öyle bunu Düşünen ve hiç Peki
yazılım düşünen var mıydı Okey 12 nights
başka 34 güzel biraz daha bunları
hareketli olması gerekiyor Bunlar önemli
konulardan bile en konulardan bir bu
yaşamadan yaşam bilimleri alanındaki
girişi size söylüyorum içinde doktorluğu
bitecek bu atsın denilen sistem içinde
gireceksiniz ve sizi artık sıradan
reçete yazan Doktorlar olmayacak mı
çıkacak Onun yerine biyomedikalin
biyoteknolojinin çok yoğun ve yapay zeka
ile en geç edilmiş çok önemli Tıp
alanlarında robotik cerrahi gibi
cerrahlık gibi çok önemli alanlar daha
da sofistike bir konuma gelecekler O
yüzden reçete doktoru bitecek yani
sabahtan akşama kadar kulak-burun-boğaz
ı bakıp gidip de dönüp de reçete yazmak
bu konu bitti olacak zaten o yüzden
Türkiye'deki Tıp eğitimi hala Türkiye'de
çok iyi o bakın tıpçıların çok çok
şikayetçi bunun en önemli sebeplerinden
birini kendini reçete doktor olup sadece
muayene Clean çalışmayı bırakanların
Çoğu bu konuda adeta bir Tamam çalışanı
pozisyonunda mutsuzlar Ve çoğu şunu
söyle ben Türkiye'nin okullarında okudum
büyük bir para kat verdim ama sonunda
kazandığım para iş takvim çok düşük bir
video bunun arkasındaki en önemli sebebi
ne bunun yeteri kadar düşünülmüş olması
Peki ne yapılması lazım
bu proteknoloji Bu alanın en önemli
alanlarından bir tanesini sevgili
gençler ne oldu sanayisi başta olmak
üzere Bu psikolojide artık Türkiye'de
sadece temel bunu bütün dünyada yaşayan
bilimleri altında bu alanlarda büyük bir
değişime büyük bir gelişimi bu da ikinci
geleceğin mesleği olarak karşımıza
çıkacak 3. maddenin 2 3. günü alanlardan
bir tanesi bakın Mühendislik alanlarında
değişim var Bunu sen bir Üniversitesi'ne
giderseniz da Fırat Üniversitesi
mühendislik fakültelerini yarıya düşürdü
nedensizce ya ya düşürmesin
sebeplerinden bir tanesi Mühendislik
fakültelerinin iki yıllık eğitimini an
özellik komedi kalıp diye tanımladığımız
2yıllık yüksekokul Lara geçirdi bi
özellik elektrik-elektronik gibi
bölümlerin endüstri gibi bölümüne
gittikçe küçüktü hangi endüstri
bölümleri Bazı üniversitelerde
Sıfırlandı bunun sebeplerinden bir
tanesi Eh ve bu öncesi artık endüstri 3D
kalmış bir sistem olduğu için endüstri
mühendisi evinin geçirip Opera şahıs
Search Ya da bilgisayar programını
altına getir
otomasyonun altına girdi bu nedenden
dolayı bugün çıkıyorsunuz endüstri
mühendislerinin çoğu işsiz Neden bugün
ne bankaya girebiliyorlar ve sanayiye
girebiliyorlar onlardan daha advan
seviyede çok daha iyi insanlar olduğu
için inanılmaz derecede sıkıntı
yaşıyorlar bundan üç hafta önce bütün
endüstri mühendisi kulüpleri beni
çağırdım Çünkü bir konuşmamda demişim ki
şimdi dediğim gibi endüstri mühendisi
bitti Bu arada Tabi ki çok büyük bir
panik bir şekilde beni çağırdığın Hoca
ne yapacağız Sen öyle diyorsun ama biz
de bunu seçtik olan oldum Ne yapacağız
Evet olan olan şimdiden olmaması
açısından tedbirli davranın Siz Proaktif
davranır endüstri mühendisi seçerken
Çünkü çok bir popüler Ya abi okuyorsa
endüstri mühendisi çok da öyle sharing
Elimizin Boğaziçi ve
çarpık olana Boğaziçi de endüstri
mühendisi bugün çoğu işsiz Neden Çünkü
geride kaldılar teknolojilerin geride
kaldı bu nedenden dolayı önce sık
seçeceksiniz makine mühendisliği bir
numara halihazırda iki
elektrik-elektronik Çünkü
Mekatronik dediğimiz alanlar inanılmaz
büyü oluyor o yüzden bu üçüncü önüne
alan Mühendislik olarak
değerlendirildiğini 4 büyük olan olarak
görülüyor İnşaat Mühendisliği 103'e
falan düştü bu arada o yüzden daha çok
ayıp ayıp mekanik aldı O yüzden size
tavsiyelerinden bir tanesi üç tane
dostane değil üç tane temel mühendislik
alanı var şu anda dörde saymazsak inşaat
mühendisliğine zaten onu Türkiye'de
Bizim işler de maalesef Karadenizliler
yapıyor O yüzden çocukların çoğunun o
kadar
iyi ise kullanılmıyor gerçekten zaman
İnşaat Mühendisliği tanımadığımız amaraj
yapan apartman yapan değil veya
gerçekten büyük Yollar Köprüler yapanlar
onun da gidebiliyorsunuz daha çok bu
işler yurtdışı mühendisliğine veriliyor
o zaman çocuklar sadece yapmaya basite
yapmaya kalıyor bu iş sizin işiniz değil
ödemsiz bundan çok daha fazlasını geri
kalan bu üç Mühendislik alanında neler
var makine elektrik elektronik ve Kimya
Mühendisliği kalıyor kimya mühendisinin
yarısı tıpta neden ilaç sektörü Çünkü
farmain dersi inanılmaz videoyu Bu
anlamda burada fark yaratan konumda bu
demek ne demek ne istemiştim yazılım
yaşam bilimleri ve Mühendislik
alanındaki bu daralma ile beraber
bakıldığını değerlendirerek onu bunu
geldikleri öğrenci adına sorduklarını
hocam bana çok çabuk bir şeyler ve ne
olursun Çok özel ihtiyacım var tam da
tercih sırasında dediğinde ben ona
yazılım yaptırdım yazılım sonrasında
ikinci yılında iki tane yol ayrılıyorum
Ya bunlar sahnesi sakar ve orada patiki
ya da mühendis Kalanına gelmeniz klanda
Bu anlamda pratik ettiği söylüyorum özel
mesela Can bu treni yaptığı iş Aslında
ne yapıyor teknolojiyle bir o alanı
birleştirdiği için milyon dolarlık
yatırım alabiliyor anlatabiliyor muyum
Ne demek istediğimi burada önemli
konulardan biri bu Bu dört çok büyüyecek
40 trilyon dolar olacak sevgili gençler
birden milyar değil bakın trilyon dolar
bu yeni endüstrinin yani 2050 2030'da
gittikçe artan 2050'de müthiş bir konuma
gelen arter nedir enerji müthiş
büyüyecek Çünkü görüyorsunuz şu anda
dünyanın en büyük krizine elektrik
kısıtlıların olacağı ve elektriğin çok
pahalanması petrole dayalı kaynağın çok
çok çok ciddi şekilde bütün ekonomileri
Ah saydığım yani altüst edici olması
Türkiye Bugün dünyanın en büyük açığı
verdi Cumhuriyet tarihinin neden bunun
sebebini Petrol fiyatlarının
istemediği şekilde dünyada artı olması
bu noktada Türkiye'nin ihracatının benim
şekilde geri kalmasına sebebiyet verdi O
yüzden ne olacak bütün dünya başta
Almanya bu işte çoktan başladı ve bu
işte siz de çok büyük bir potansiyel
alternatif enerji kaynakları kombine
ediyorum lazım Lütfen bateriler mi
istiyorsunuz Ne istiyorsanız burun
kullanırsınız toryumu kullanırsın su
enerjisini kullanırsınız Rüzgar
enerjisini kullanırsınız bunun için
solar panel olduğum üretirsiniz bıdı
bıdı Ne yaparsınız buna bakıyorum biraz
güzel bir örnek vereyim Ben çok
impressed etmişti
biz bu konuyu Biliyoruz tabii ki
dünyanın üniversitelerine istediğini bir
öğrenci evi Ama bu ay çiçekler gibi aynı
zamanda dönen değil kapının açılan dır
soruların panel üretimi bunları şehirler
için ürettiği özellikle çok estetik
üretti Bugün şu anda getirin en önemli
çünkü yazıya geçen yıl kalmıştı geçerdi
sana İncirlik adı altında bir bölüme
bu söylemesine rağmen bu çocuğa özel fon
çıkartıp değildi Neden bakın Sadece
tabiatta iyi bir omuz örerek iyi izleyin
ve onun transform Elif bir şey
değerlendirdiğimizde sizi Eğer dünyanın
bir ihtiyacı varsa size hemen kapıyor
lar Nerede olursanız olsun kaplıyorlar
bu nedenden dolayı O noktada inanılmaz
önemi altyapı var bu alternatif enerji
konusu tekrar Altını çiziyorum
Ukrayna Rusya Savaşı öncesindeki bütçe
expect giden beklenen rakam otur yoğundu
sonraki dönem Şu son iki ay içinde
çıkartmam Birce 40 trilyon dolara geldi
V alan en önemli V alan hangisi Peki
Design her 13 çocuktan bir tanesinin el
çizme kabiliyeti var Eyvallah bu Tamam
ama bizim bahsettiğimiz Design şişe
çizmek değil hani alanları koyarsın
hemde bir türlü ayarlayamadım kontör
elma tut tut Ne oldu üzerinden
bahsetmiyorum bu bu tasarımdan Busenaz
tabletinden bahsetmiyor biz aynı
dediğimiz şey Renault gibi vik etkenler
gibi somut verileri kullanarak bir olayı
tasarlamak yapıp bakın bir ürün buradaki
bir ürünü görüyorsunuz Bu önüne
ergonomik olması benim şekilde beni
birşey oluşturuyor olması bir flash
teskin olması veya olmaması bütün
bunları Dizayn açısından
değerlendirildiği nizi müthiş bir şey
bilmiyor biliyor musunuz İsrail gibi
çocuk geliştirmiş Versace kendi bugün
bakın milyonlarca adet satıyor Bunu biz
ne diyoruz Dizayn ediyoruz buna nasıl
değerlendiriyoruz bir zaman için kendi
bir model var Stanford Üniversitesi'nin
geliştirdiği ve dünyaya marka olarak
dağıttığı bir eğitim programı dünyada
insanın ihtiyacı olan insanların
problemlerini görerek onların
ihtiyaçları karşılayan ve ona bir model
oluşturan bir kısım Bu anlamda çok
önemli ajandalar karşımıza çıkıyor o
zaman sizden bu en konulardan bir tanesi
kendinizin kim olduğunu kim olduğunuzu
biliyorsunuz lazım satıcı yetenek
yönetimi yapılması lazım nedir
kabiliyetlerini ezme Ceren izle bakın
yüzüm bakıldığını bin Demir
farklılığımız Biz yapıyor geliyor
projesine göre
199.99 biz Aslında aynıyız ama
hiçbirimizin gözü göbeğinde çıkıyor mu
Hayır ama bizim bizi yapan en önemli
özellik Gözünüz oradaki binde bir
farklılığımız önemi aynı şey genetik
faktörlerin dışında bir o kadardı ilgi
alanlarınız becerileriniz Bunların hepsi
size bir özellik getiriyor ve hep şunu
söylüyorlar hep duymuşsunuzdur Steve
söylüyor yani olmaz söylüyorum Her biri
söylüyor diyorlar ki tutkuyla
çalıştığınız iş severek çalıştığınız işi
seçmelisiniz Evet bunu nasıl
bulacaksınız O yüzden bunu mutlaka bunu
değerlendir olması lazım bir üniversite
hocası ol bu işte alanında çalışan bir
profesör olarak Profesör alalım Bu aynı
zamanda bu alanda dünyanın her
Üniversitesi'ne Girip çıkıp kimsenin
girmediği halde Ema ikisinden ok sordun
Atatürk Üniversitesi'nden pek
Üniversitesi ne kadar bütün iç detayları
bilen bir hoca Türkiye'deki detaylı da
bilendir hocalar şunu söyleyebilirim ki
üniversite eğitimden bir şey beklemeyin
sevgili gençler sevgili aileler Çünkü
100'de 95'i çöp oldu neden çok oldu bunu
açıkça söylüyorum Neden çünkü hoca
sadece Facebook Twitter oldu yani
destekleyicisi oldu Hoca çok gelin Hani
Yılmaz'ın söylediği gibi Bazı
üniversitelerde Hatta öğrenci
gönderdiğinizde beyni küçültüyor Aynı
fikirdeyim beyni küçültüyor yani çocuğu
o kadar ütülüyor ve o en güzel yıllarını
o kadar zor geçiriyor ki bunu bile
kaldırmadan Bu arada bütün büyük trenler
büyük üçüncü eder giderken çocuk burada
Hala dandik Bugün sizlerle top çeviri
oluyor bu mücadeleden dolayı
üniversite eğitimini Ben söylemiyorum
bunu Google Google yapan
Üniversitesi elektrik-elektronik Bölümü
Başkanı diyor ki biz Eskiden bir eğitim
verirdik ve bu eğitim Eskiden 13 ile 15
yıl
güncelliğini korurdu bugün ise 8aylık 5
aya indi bu sürece Yani sen taze ekmek
gibi çıkmış yeni öğrenci aldığında gün
öğrenci Türkiye'nin veya dünyanın en iyi
Üniversitesi'nden mezun olabilir Peki
A5 ay ay sonra da 8'er sonra öğrenci o
bilgiyi on Oha vıdı
kaybediyor Bu anlamda Neden Çünkü çok
hızlı inanılmaz hepsi bir dünya
teknoloji dijitalleşme ile geliyor ve bu
anlamda Siz Eğer bunları yapamazsanız
çok büyük bir krize giriyorsunuz O
yüzden neye oy verdi sevgili gençler
sevgiler değişti size mezuniyetin ilk
başta değil En sonda yer alıyor artık
nereden hangi okuldan mezun olduğunuz
ama isminizi altında Aslında olmasını
gerektiren konular ne siyasetler hangi
becerilere sahipsin Neler yapabilirsin
bunların arasında Neyi oluşturabilirsin
buna bakıyorlar önümüzde 2025 ve mm
32051 belirleyen şimdi dört tane önemli
de Jerry aranıyor bunu altyapıları var
Bunları al parametre var ve bu
parametrenin içinde dört tanesi çok
önemli bir problem çözme becerisi ne
olursa olsun Çabuk problemi çözebilecek
beceriye sahip olabilmek hemen nasıl
olabileceğini görebilmek
değerlendirebilmek bu çok önemli
noktalardan biri problem çözme
becerisinin Çubuk olabilmesi buna çok
cevap ailene görmek buna Biz ne diyoruz
ya kışın çok çabuk Reaksiyon verebilmek
morali bu Ama bu anlamda çok önemli
konulardan bir tanesi Problem çözerken
ha başkasının problemini değil mi önce
kendi problemlerini de çözerek başlamak
bu ev konulardan bir tanesi Sonrasında
ne Saf ki insanın kendisine bakması çok
önemli bugün inanılmaz derecede
öğrencilerimize dikkat eksikliği var var
mı arkadaştır oluyor dikkat eksikliği
konsantrasyon sıkıntısı anne ve babalar
görmüyor musunuz hocalarım derse
Girdikten Beş dakika sonra çocuklar
dikkatleri dağılıyor Sen istediğin kadar
burada şap tabanlık yap Yine olmuyor
çünkü Dedem öğrenci çok dağılmış konumda
neden diye söylersen size söyleyeyim çok
masumca Bir bilgisayarın ve çok basınca
çok ders çalışıyor bile olsa kuantum
fizik bile çalışıyorsa telefonun ya da
iPad'in veya bilgisayarın Umay ışığına
maruz kalması bile yeter Bu bir
öğrencinin bu ön sonra kalanın distrust
dolmasına dokunun veya hormon dengesinin
bozulmasına yeterli bir sebep olabiliyor
O yüzden Dikkat eksikliğinin en önemli
sebeplerinden biri kullandığımız gıdanın
şeker karbonhidrat ve süt ürünün
aşırılığı
hayırlı dağların yerine ve Üzerine de
bir de dopamin çok fazla derecede
saldıran oyunlar instagramlar tiktoklar
bakıldığında inanılmaz dönem var ve
şöyle söyleniyor bakıp özellikle Şimdi
size söyleyebilirim burada bir kısmınız
var
2025 yılı
mezunlarından itibaren bir TikTok
dünyası da geliyor oraya Amerika bile
ulaşamıyor o Dünya çok daha farklı bir
ya da discordlar var Onlar Bunlar var
ailenin hiç farkında olmadığı inanılmaz
bir dijital platformların çocuklar
tarafından ileri seviyede kullanılması
söz konusu ve hocaları bunlardan haberi
bile yok O ne oluyor bambaşka yaratılmış
bir sanal dünyada gençler bunu
oluşturuyorlar bunu değerlendiriyorlar
özel en önemli ikincisi cassette dediğim
gibi problem çözme kendi problemlerini
yanıtını kendine bakma özelliklerini çok
iyi tutuyor olmanız lazım bu çok önemli
noktalardan bir tanesi üçüncüsü
ulusal yerel ve uluslararası düzeyde
işbirliği yapabilme becerisi o cesareti
bulabilme verirsin sevgili arkadaşlar
Eskiden İngilizce öğrenmeye yurtdışına
girdilerine saç baş ayı şimdi dünyanın
en iyi Yunus ya ne gibi hareket gibi
İngilizce öğreten okulları okullarını
kapattılar artık sicillerin çünkü online
var Onlarla artık istediğiniz dili
İstediğiniz şekilde öğrenebilirsiniz o
kolaborasyon sağlayabilirsiniz bir sürü
aplikasyonlar bir sürü korseyle İyidir
eksik gibi birçok müthiş bu inanılmaz
platformlar var burada her ingilizcenizi
hem yabancı dil başka yabancı dile ve en
önemlisi ise Tabii ki kodlama yönü
olmamız lazım size şunu söylüyorum 21
yüzyılın 22 yüzyılın gençleri İngilizce
bilmezseniz treni çoktan kaçırdınız Ha
bir de üzerine yazılım bilmezsiniz
eyvahlar olsun o yüzden bu iki tane
alanda bu mutlaka isterseniz sanat
tarihi okulun hiç fark etmez buradaki
yetkiniz arttırırız Evet hocam ben nasıl
yapacağım Çok basit
code.org Agir bedava dersler İyidir
yüksek bir harren Siz Computer sensin
yani fitil de bir ders var anne ve
babaları Bir de öneriyorum bunu
öğrensinler diye çünkü bunlar inanılmaz
derecede basit yazılımlar şeklinde
öğretiliyor ve siz kaçtan başlanan Beş
yaşındaki çocuğu üniversite öğrencisiyle
aynı kitabı kutumuz emanetini bitti mi
var bende Türkçesi bu etmiştim sıkı kaç
gibi bir konuyu bir de mantıklı
öğreteceğiz konumda yani işte pencil
demek kadar kolay mantıklı bir şekilde
hem geleceği hem de yazılımı
öğrenebilirsiniz Özen bu anlamda Bu kol
operasyonları gidip bir hedef
doğrultusunda 7 olmanız lazım sonuncusu
bununla bağlantılı dördüncü Önemli olan
ne teknolojiyi kullanabilmek teknoloji
ilk kullanabilmek ama daha daha da
önemlisi teknolojiyi çok iyi bulup
edebilecek düzeyde olabilmek O yüzden
sevgili Gençler benim son sözlerim Bunu
sen zaten zamanında olduğunu düşünüyorum
Bu anlamdaki en önemlisi de
tavsiyelerinden bir tanesi sadece
akademik büyümeyi değil bunun yanında
Skin diye tanımladığımız beceri setleri
nizip'e Jared emeklerinizi
zenginleştirmek Ve tabii ki her zamanki
gibi özelliği İkincisi çok önemli konu
biliyorsunuz noktalardan
o
çocuk Eğer depresyondaysa
Depresyonda olması İkinci derece önemli
öğrenci acı problemi çözüp benim
depresyon vardı diğer de almayı
öğrenmesi gerekiyor Anladın mı Ondan
sonra depresyonu çözecek Özen bizim için
önemli konulardan bir tanesi gençlerin
ruh sağlıklarının çok önemli sevmek
motivasyonlarını arttırmak Onlara
gelecek sunma ve bu anlamda Buna göre
değerlendirmek gerekir Bugün size
Samimiyeti şunu söyleyebilirim ki
öğrencilerin arasında buna yaşıyorum
hoşuma geldiği için öyle dedi
gelebiliyor bana danışa biliyor ki
Robert bitirmiş Boğaziçi de bunu yapmış
Master dizisini yapıp 8 10 bin lira para
kazanamayan var bu gerçek Burada iki
tane büyük problem var Birincisi öğrenci
kendi seçtiği alanı kendi Uygun olmadığı
için bu da Katlanıyor İkincisi ise
Türkiye'nin koşulları bu bu bu Yapı
içinde öğrenci ön görememiş o sektörün
bittiğini anlatabiliyor muyum ne demek
yok ama aynı sınıf arkadaşı 20 bin euro
ile başlıyor işe Hatta aralarında 600
bin 800 bin bir milyon dolar kazandı var
milyon dolarlar kazanan varsa
kitaplarını açanlar var Bu anlamda bunu
değerlendirir olmak gerekir ve gençler
sevgili anne ve babalar
çocuklarınıza en büyük yapacağımız en
önemli mantık anlıyorum Tabii ki onların
bir baltaya sap olmadı bekliyorsunuz ama
dünyasını 20 lerinizi start-up mantıklı
anlamalarını sağ toplardan nasıl yol
alındığını görüyor olmanız lazım Çünkü
Türkiye'nin geleceği bu tür önerimiz
tarta projelerinden geçiyor Bugün
Finans mantığını öğretmez çocukları
kaybedeceğiz kuru farklılıklarından
bahsetmiyorum final teknolojilerinden
bahsediyorum en önemli konulardan bir
tanesi blok Çin diye geçen çok kıymetli
ve çok önemli bir büyü dalgayı
kaybediyoruz Herkes bu da para
kaybetmeyi da atıyor ama öyle
öğrencilerin var ki Amerika'daki okul
parasını 400.000 doları bir yıllık
kazanıldı var burada ben risk alma risk
Yönetmeyi kavramlarını öğreterek
tedbirin davrandığının çocukları bu tür
teknolojilerin üretilmesinden yanayım
yani dünya uçuyor Türkiye'de büyük bir
kıymet var bunu bizi mutlaka hocalar
olarak aileler olarak Mecidiye olmamız
ve Bu gençleri yolunu açıyor olmamız
gerekiyor Bizim de görevimiz bu yolda
onlara ne için yaptığı gibi değil onlara
sadece el verme omuzlarınıza çıkartıp
yükselmelerini ve yücelerin sağlamak
Umarım çok yüksek çok güzel ve çok
aydınlık olan bir Gideceğiniz olması
dileğiyle çok teşekkür ediyoruz